in 2013 I do the interview with Piers
Morgan on CNN about control and it goes
absolutely berserk I dare you accuse me
of standing on the grades of the
children that die there how dare you
I've seen you do it repeatedly Pier like
I say how dare you I mean you can keep
saying that but you've done it
repeatedly up until that point in our
partnership I was the business guy and
Jeremy going to be the talent because
he'd always want to be a director and
and he came to LA to be an actor and
after the interview he called me up and
he said we have this completely
backwards I'm the business guy and
you're the talent so that was all credit
to him on that one I mean that takes an
act of humility truly to to be able to
say like you need to be the front man
when you've always thought you were the
front man now it's great Jeremy also
gets to be a front man but at the time
that was a really big Revelation so that
was Revelation number one